Well, they
have arrested the two suspects in the
shooting at a home depot, it's just
such, Cristian Cásseres greets you, according
to the Las Vegas storm police, they
discussed before the shooting,
it is also revealed that the men were
arrested in Texas and at this moment it is not
known when  they will be extradited to nevada
the hong guy employee who was shot
continues to recover in the hospital the
conception at the cobit spawn test site
in that is, it has not been the same as
the other sites in the valley the
party site just opened and the flow of
traffic in  parking was minimal
and they still have appointments available
throughout this week
the public is reminded that the hours of service are
from noon to 8 pm from
Saturday to Wednesday this site will
remain open for the next few
weeks
the painting tenth parade in tribute  The
martin luther king july was held this
morning in downtown las vegas among
those who paraded are the
honor guards d  the police department in las
vegas' the parade route started on
4th street and work was closed
from carlsten street to chubut street
and we started the week with a
cloudy day temperatures will rise to
60 degrees by this monday and the
chances of rain will return
tonight and early tomorrow
later in the week there will be a slight
increase in temperatures with
sunny skies I am cristian cásseres with super
informative from initiate in Spanish good
day
[Music]